okay so guess I'll talk about the
computational complexity of estimating a
time to convergence and this is work
with Andrea Bob Donovan alcaman muscle
so so maybe this the the theme of this
talk is a little bit contrary to other
talks because we're talking about no
hardness results so so the motivation is
that mcmc is widely used in practice and
doing inference and in various
applications such as image processing
and so on and we know that you know the
theory tells us that eventually the
chain will converge to your desired
distribution but in practice you may or
may not have bounds on the mixing time
and even when you do have bounds they
may not be practical about to simulate
for that long so so people who actually
code markov chains and and run them they
want to be able to tell well are the
samples that i'm getting are they you
know good for doing inferences and in
practice they use a number of
statistical tests which are called
convergence diagnostics so so i'll just
quickly say that you know this the setup
again is going to be that we're looking
at a markov chain em on some finite
space Omega and it has transition matrix
P and stationary distribution pie and
where we're looking at the epsilon
mixing time which is defined as the
first time T where this distance D T
goes below epsilon and DT is the total
variation distance between the t-step
started T sub distributions for worst
pair of state and we'll also look at the
mixing time when
you start from a particular state and
look at the first time that the total
variation distance between the t-step
distribution and pi is less than epsilon
so so coming back to these convergence
diagnostics years so I mentioned some
visual Diagnostics that people use so
here's a really common one called the
trace plot and what what is happening
here is that you look at you know some
some particular dimension of your you
know markov chain configuration maybe
some feature and your your and the
x-axis you're plotting the iteration
number and you're plotting the value at
the iteration just seeing this versus
time and if you go to something like
this statistical analysis software the
users guide to assessing markov chain
convergence they have these pictures and
they tell you well if you see something
like the top left picture where you know
the mean seems to be fairly constant and
and you're also varying fairly
constantly around the mean then that's
that's a good thing and you know in this
picture here you see that you might want
to throw away some of the iterations in
the beginning but then it seems like
you're back to the first picture and the
bottom two pictures are bad this one
doesn't seem to have a constant mean at
all and that one this picture things
seem to be moving fairly slowly around
the mean okay so that that is one very
commonly used
diagnostic and of course you know we
understand that while seeing a picture
like this might be necessary for
convergence it's it's not sufficient and
it's probably easy to cook up examples
where it's not sufficient six I mean you
might at least think that picture too is
a bit better than picture what substance
I mean it looks like something that
thing happened yeah maybe that's right i
think they say something like um i think
they say that here the convergence is
pretty fast and you know right away
things things are looking quite good but
but you know i don't think that that
they are unaware of the fact that these
are not conclusive that they don't you
know conclusively tell you that you have
converged okay and then you know they in
addition to these visual sort of tests
there are a number of statistical tests
that people have come up with one very
common one is this first Gelman Ruben
test where you're running multiple
copies of your Markov chain from
different starting points and comparing
you know how much your observable is
varying within the chains to how much is
the variance between the copies of the
chain and things of that sort and the
idea being that you know if you have
some very multimodal distribution then
maybe if you had a way of taking
multiple starting points from the
different modes then you know that would
get that would at least overcome the
problem of not seeing a moat at all okay
so so so as I said you know they're not
unaware that that diagnostic scan fail
in various scenarios so what we wanted
to do in this work was maybe abstract
out what exactly
does it mean to to diagnose whether
convergence has occurred can we just
frame this as a computational problem
and understand how how hard it is and
you know the other the other thing maybe
is that you will see various papers
where where somebody will say well look
this this diagnostic it actually fails
to to show you that there is non
convergence but here I've come up with
this other diagnostic and and this will
detect non convergence so how can we put
sort of how can we frame the problem of
convergence with as many restrictions as
possible and still show that this is a
hard thing so okay so what we start with
saying is that a Markov chain is going
to be a rule for determining the next
state given the state right now which is
a string of length n just a 01 string of
length N and some randomness so we'll
say that a circuit of this type
specifies the transition matrix P if
your probability that the circuit
outputs the state Y given X and the
randomness is exactly equal to the
transition probability ok so so this is
the Markov chain and what should a
diagnostic algorithm do well it should
have access to this circuit for
simulating the chain and you might want
to allow it to simulate the chain for
some time T and then ask it to decide at
time T is the chain within one quarter
total variation distance or are you
still at least one-quarter internal
version distance away from PI so so
that's the first attempt and one one
thing to note about this is that you're
asking for something pretty stringent
you're asking it to tell you kind of at
time T you know exactly what what the
distance is so you might want to relax
this a little bit and you could you
could do the following you could say
well I just want an algorithm which
tells me
at time T if the variation distance is
below and eight I say mixed and if it's
still at least a half I see not mixed
and in the other cases I'm allowed to
make a mistake so you're allowing some
sort of gap in your approximation to the
distance you could go even further and
say well I will say mixed if I'm below
and ate at time T but if I run for some
constant C times T C can be big and
still I'm a half away from stationarity
then I say not mixed okay so so this
this is this last is the formulation
that will look at so here are three
versions of the problem that that is all
might be interesting to look at so the
first one test convergence with two
parameters C and Delta is kind of the
most most general version where you have
very little information on what the
chain is doing so your input to this
problem is the circuit see a starting
state X and a time T that you want to
run for and the only thing you're told
is that PSR got it and then you'd like
to say yes you know at time T I'm the
little quarter minus Delta and or any
other case if I've run for C times D i'm
still above a quarter plus delta
so so one thing that's that's maybe
missing here is that you know we haven't
said anything about cases where you
actually have a bound on the mixing time
and so to to encode that we have the
second version of the problem so these
Polly test convergence where the input
is now your circuit for simulating the
chain your time t and t max which is
some bound on the mixing time and what
you'd like the algorithm to do is run in
time that's polynomial in this bound on
the mixing time and the way the way
you've encoded that is is by giving the
input ok so again we want to distinguish
these two cases and one thing that that
we haven't done here is taken an initial
starting state so we've just said you're
at an arbitrary starting state and you
want to distinguish these duties but you
could also say suppose I also know the
starting state which is true in many
cases in practice you know people are
choosing their starting States sometimes
cleverly and saying I diagnose
convergence so so that's this third
problem polynomial testing convergence
with some initial state which is X in
the input ok and then you want to
distinguish these two cases the total
variation distance to stationarity start
it at X okay so so I'm just going to go
through results that we know about these
these three problems and maybe tell you
a little bit about how you how you show
them all right so so our first problem
is the most general one and this turns
out to be doable in p space and also
pspace hard so maybe that's not too
surprising but in in any case so if you
haven't seen a piece base before it's a
or don't remember
work it's the set of all decision
problems which a Turing machine can
decide using a polynomial amount of
space in the input ok so so what I'll
tell you about is showing the second
part of the result which is that the
problem is pspace hard and so if you
think about what you need to do to show
p space hardness you would like to take
a piece based hard problem and reduce
from it to some instance of this testing
convergence problem and what you'd like
to be able to do is when you have an
input to your piece phase complete
problem which is I say yes then you
would like the mixing time maybe to be
small and when it's a no instance then
you'd like to mixing time to be large so
you want to serve example like this okay
so so here is what we can do so so start
with some pspace complete problem let's
call it eight and i'm going to draw here
the the computation graph of the turing
machine ta which decides it so so again
it just just as a reminder what is your
Turing machine doing it's got some some
tape that it's going over and it has
some state at each time and it reads a
bit and looks at its state is there some
finite number of states
that the machine can be in it reads the
bit here the state tells it what to
write and whether it move left or right
okay so so these these nodes in the
computation graph they encode
configuration which is what's on the
tape what is the state of the machine
and where is it pointing okay so so
what's going to happen is it out of each
node you have one one edge coming out
because you know where to go next and
we'll look at two to three special
special nodes so this one is the exact
state this one is the reject state and
this orange one corresponds to the
starting configuration for a particular
input okay so so for example this
corresponds to an input on which the
Turing machine accepts because you see
that there's this path to the except
note so here is the reduction out of
this we we construct a Markov chain as
follows so the states of the Markov
chain are just the configurations of the
Turing machine and we're going to get
rid of the directions and for each edge
which you see in the configuration graph
you put in one of these pink edges and
have to make it up weight W and put a
put a self loop at each node and then
you connect this except state with the
reject state with a with a hedge of
weight one and lastly you connect the
reject state with the start state with
an edge of weight W also
and this turned out to be enough if you
choose w carefully to be able to
distinguish the yes and no cases and you
can sort of see from the picture why
because suppose you're in the yes case
and there is a path from s to a so
they're in the same component so you see
that you know in in in this graph
somehow it seems to be fairly easy to
get from 8s but if you think about what
might happen in the no case when s is
not in the same component as a then you
know in order to get from sta you would
have to go through this edge of white
one and and you'd like to make that sort
of a lightweight edge compared to w okay
so so the idea is fairly fairly
straightforward the only things that you
need to be careful about our kind of the
exact settings of the parameters for
example you've actually got to choose
this weight W so that your reduction is
in polynomial time which is something
that that you need to do for peace based
reductions for example okay so so so
here's a little bit of a argument you
know why you can do that so so we first
look at the yes case and you observe
that not just in the last case but in
general each state of the Markov chain
has some constant degree right and this
is because you know the out degrees in
this graph are one and the indegree is
something constant because there's a
constant number of states of the machine
okay so let's call that boundary d and
so we're going to say that the mixing
time is upper bounded in terms of the
the inverse square of the conductance
and we'll put a put a lower bound on the
conductance here so if you want to lower
bound the conductance you notice that if
you take any
set of the vertices here there's always
a w-wait edge coming out of it okay and
moreover you can upper bound the the
total weight of edges inside the set by
d x to the n times though the weight of
the edges so your conductance is lower
bounded by this quantity you can also
get a lower bound on the minimum
stationary probability because the
stationary probability is just
proportional to the the edge weights
going into a vertex ok so putting all
that together gives you that you have an
upper bound on the mixing time of
something like D cube 2 to the power 3
yet ok so what you'd like to show is
that in the no case you will get
significantly a larger mixing time if
you choose w appropriately so how can
you argue about the lower bound you say
well suppose that I start two copies of
this chain on on the graph let's say X T
starts at s + YT starts at the vertex a
then what is the distance between the
t-step distributions of XT and YT at
time T well you can lower bound it by
the probability that X T hasn't reached
this component minus the chance that
there's a time T where there's time T
prime where Y T prime has gone over into
the component of s and you know you can
see that because of the loops the the
chance of leaving the components in any
step is at most one over W so a Union
bound will give you that the distance at
time T is at least 1-2 t / w and this
this lets us compute that in order to
get within one quarter plus delta
variation distance you would need to go
for time w / for all right so so all we
need to do now is set W to be large
enough so I've taken it to be you know
the stretching factor' see in the time
the upper bound from the yes case and
times some constants that we need and to
finish the reduction take your starting
state to the s and the time that you you
will run for to be the upper bound on on
the gasket so this this will finish the
reduction so so that's piece of a is
hard right that's right so so it's so
you see it's okay to choose w to be this
large because you have polynomial time
so you need to be able to compute this
in polynomial time right so so your
circuit has to be able to say take a
weight WR edge of Lake one essentially
and since W can be represented with
polynomial in any bits that's
okay all right so so the next the next
problem was when we have a bound on the
mixing time and in this case what we
show is that assuming some bound on on
this on this stretch in the time that
that you look at the problem is co
np-hard so so the proof is through you
know another another one of these
reductions from a co NP complete problem
and maybe I'll just say quickly what it
is so so the reduction is from
unsatisfiable ax t which means that if
your input is a formula sigh CNF formula
sigh then if it doesn't have any
satisfying assignments then you are then
you are you know unsatisfiable okay so
so the reduction is the following you
think of your formula is represented by
the verses of the bouillon cube and the
Markov chain is going to be defined by
taking weight one on all the edges of
the cube and the following thing so
whenever you have a vertex of the cube
corresponding to an unsatisfying
assignment to put a self loop of weight
n and when you have a vertex
corresponding to a satisfying assignment
you put a loop of weight n to the D
where D will be some constant that we
decide bigger than one so you're so
you're sort of slowing down with self
loops the chain at these satisfying
assignments okay so what is the point
the point is that if you start out with
the formula that is unsatisfiable then
this is just you know the lazy random
walk on the cube because you've got half
probability of staying and half of
moving to
random note and so you can upper bound
your mixing time by my constant that
depends on delta x n log n on the other
hand if you think about what happens
here then again you can make the same
sort of argument that you can lower
bound the distance at time T for two
copies of the chain because you could
start with one of the satisfying
assignments and you could start with the
vertex which is diagonally opposite to
it and the point being that you can
bound the distance between the t-step
distributions by saying well you know
what's the probability that this guy
stays here for for time T and doesn't
leave it and at the same time what is
the chance of this this copy of the
chain going and hitting it during that
time will be exponentially small okay so
okay so maybe I will
the calculations but the idea is very
similar that we can show this gap in the
mixing time in these two cases okay so
so the last problem is we have a bound
on the mixing time and some particular
starting state so in fact if you look at
the reduction that we did in the last in
the second problem you can you can
actually know so so the result that that
we have here is the following so the
hardness is is this second piece and it
says that if you're stretching is
bounded by t max over T times some
constant then TCS should just be Polly
test con initial then that is sdk hard
so what is sdk it stands for statistical
zero knowledge so it turns out that that
this particular complexity class which
is studied by people and cryptography
sort of captures the hardness of this
problem so so where does this come from
so it comes from this idea of having
proof systems in complexity and the way
it goes is that say you have a language
L that you're trying to decide so a
proof system
proof system consists of an algorithm V
which has the following properties so if
you give it a string X which is in the
language then there is some proof pie so
that you can you can give pie to V and V
will output except and on the other hand
if X is not in the language then any
proof that you give it doesn't have
caused it to accept it will output
reject and you'd like V to run in time
this polynomial in X and so you so this
is sort of another way that that the
class NP is is also defined and you can
see a you know the familiar sort of case
of SAT where where the proof is just the
satisfying assignment so the question
you can ask about this is you know when
I give you a satisfying assignment to
convince you that the formula is
satisfiable how much knowledge are you
gaining from verifying that it is an
assignment so for example you know at
it's not a formal thing but at some
level for example you gain the ability
to convince someone else that the
formula is a satisfying assignment take
this assignment and give it to someone
else in and and convince them so you
could say somehow that that you know
something else about the problem besides
the fact that the formula is satisfiable
so people wanted to come up with proof
systems where you don't have sort of
this leaking of information so
Goldwasser McCauley and Rakoff defined
this notion of zero knowledge proofs
we're now you have approval p and
they're trying to convince verifier v of
some assertion and v learns nothing but
the truth of of the assertion so if
you're seeing this for the first time
it's kind of surprising that I think
it's surprising that that such things
can
exist and then again you have the same
types of requirements from this
interaction between the prover and
verifier you want completeness so that
if the string is in the language then we
accepts it after seeing you know the
interaction between the prover and the
verifier with some probability better
than to third so I didn't say but the
proven verifier allowed to now toss
coins you have soundness so if X is not
in the language then for anything that
the prover tells you we would only
accept with bounded probability and the
verifier is efficient so where does zero
knowledge come in so the way of defining
zero knowledge is to say that the entire
interaction could have been simulated by
the verifier so so meaning that so so
somehow this captures the fact that V is
not learning anything outside the true
solution okay so I won't you know go
into formally what what how that's done
but you can then talk about statistical
zero knowledge or SC k which is the
class of languages where there's an
interaction between the prover and the
verifier that's statistically
indistinguishable from the simulator
with zero knowledge that the verifier
could run and you know the point being
that this is in contrast to things like
computational zero knowledge where the
verifier is restricted to be
where the verifier you know has to be
computationally bounded so maybe I
should mention that you know one idea is
that when you're having this leaking of
information you could think of verifiers
who are who are not honest who are not
you know running the protocol for for
deciding this problem rather you know
they could cheat and try to gain some
extra information from the proofer okay
so that's why there are these
restrictions of statistical and
computational on the verifier okay so so
in in case the canonical hard problem
for this class s ck is statistical
difference and so it's quite simple to
state you have an input which is two
circuits C and C Prime and they are
outputting distributions mu1 and mu2 / 0
1 to the N and in the yes instances the
circuits are outputting distributions
which are have total variation distance
which is at least a parameter C and in
the no instance is there the
distributions are close together there's
an upper bound on the on the total
variation distance
so high-end vidonne showed that as long
as there's some gap between this
completeness parameter and the soundness
parameter the problem statistical
difference is in the class SDK so there
is a statistical zero-knowledge protocol
for this problem and for any any values
of the parameters snc problem is hard
for a ck and and one note about sdk is
that it's believed to contain problems
and sorry it contains problems that are
believed to be hard such as graph non
isomorphism but but it is believed that
it doesn't contain NP complete problems
yeah sorry letter said this certainly
started dropping distributions is that
like yours where they giving you the
next step with an arc of cherin order no
no so you just think of the distribution
/ 01 to the end that is being output by
this circuit so mr. key well so so I
have a circuit and I'm putting inputs
into it and then I'm just getting some
distribution over the bouillon cube
because
alright so so so once we have this
complete problem it kind of we don't
have to bother with essentially don't
have to bother with zero knowledge
protocols and so on if we want to show
hardness at least because we just want
to take an instance of this statistical
difference problem and reduce it to our
problem so we take this input which is
two circuits C and C Prime and we'll
take settings of the parameters where c
is equal to 1 and s is a quarter minus
Delta and the idea for constructing the
Markov chain in this case is is the
following so I'm going to construct a
Markov chain on the product space of
capital M hypercubes yes okay this is M
guys like this and so the way the way
the transitions of the chain work are
you choose your add some state ytz T
which is a pair in in you know em and
some some point in the hypercube if you
happen to be at the first point of em
then you're going to choose the next
point in the hypercube according to mu 1
and if you're at the second point then
choose according to mu 2 and if you're
at any of the other points you just stay
where you are in the hypercube
so all right and then at the next step
you move within em uniformly at random
so you can if you think about it you
find that the stationary distribution of
this chain is going to be uniform over m
in in this dimension and you know drawn
from you one the average of me one on
youtube okay so you can write down
fairly exactly an expression for the
distance to stationarity when you're
starting at this this state so it's one
in em and it's at the point 0 0 0 in the
hypercube and basically the the
variation distance is captured by the
variation distance between mu1 and mu2
okay and and you know of course this
factor is here because some of the time
minus 2 over m of the time you're you're
not really doing anything to get closer
to the stationary distribution okay so
all right so now in the yes case
I have it backward so so this should
actually read the no case so in the null
case your total variation distance
between mu1 and mu2 is upper bounded by
s and so you can upper bound the
distance of the t-step distribution from
stationarity and on the other hand you
can lower bound in the yes case the
t-step distribution from stationarity
and as long as the time that you run for
is not too large then you would get from
here that the distance is at least a
quarter plus delta okay so so that's
sort of how you get this gap in these
two cases and in both cases you can show
that the mixing time is has an upper
bound of em that follows just from the
fact that this distance would be founded
and this is no more than one okay so so
that is how you do that fat reduction
and and so maybe just a few words in
conclusion so we don't believe that
efficient algorithms exist for these
classes that we've shown these problems
are hard for and you know this this
implies that for the particular versions
of diagnostic algorithms that we've
considered there shouldn't exist
algorithms efficient algorithms Don
Woodard asked us an interesting question
which was can you show hardness for
diagnosing convergence from a given
state or Kenny show hardness of
diagnosing convergence when you know a
PI up to some global constant because
that's often the case in Markov chains
that we look at and so if you if you
look carefully at the co NP reduction
where we don't have a given starting
state in that case the stationary
distribution is is easy because you know
it's just proportional to either n or n
to the D right so this could certainly
be sort of output
by some circuit on the other hand if you
think about the SDK reduction then in
order to show hardness in that case you
would need to reduce from some SDK
complete problem where you know your
distribution's mu1 and mu2 are somehow
known to you or at least you know in our
reduction that might be helpful so we
don't know how to do that and then
another another class of algorithms that
you might want hardness for our maybe
give samplers so meaning that you have
an efficient way to canoe you know
output the conditional distribution of
each variable given the ones around it
and
but in complement this was positive
result when relaxing and further the
requirements are there no stick Frances
soon more assumptions on the transition
rates or in particular if I this T
versus City but maybe c is not the
content but allowed to grow say my
mixing time is no give the bounce to
distinguish whether the mixing time is
bigger than n cube or less than anything
like that work so people are going to
keep using diagnostics whether we tell
them not so are they or some then say
well your diagnostic can't do as well as
you would wish but you know here is some
positive results the compliments all the
you know I like to tell them that their
that they fit with Agnes will fail as
almost as much as you do but at some
point they want you to give them some
point all right so um okay so so see you
well so in these results you see it I
think so it doesn't necessarily have to
be a constant right because supposed to
have a random walk on the graphs I know
all the transition probabilities are at
least one of our angular so mean
obviously your results indicate you need
to lock Morris need some stronger
assumptions this with probabilities are
all you're awful not too small right
there will be sorry
so the same direction so that is the
problem that is our SDK or is it also
contains a messy thing right so so if
you have the right amount of gap then
then it is contained in so I think so um
so sdk is in am intersect khoi khoi am
that's right and so you would believe
that it's in NP intersect co MP yeah so
so it's it's not always its I guess when
you have enough of a gap in the total
variation distance that answer your
question
don't you have the last question